- [Instructor] Pause this video
and see if you can
evaluate this expression
before we do it together.
All right, now let's
work on this together.
And we see that we have a lot
of different operations here.
We have exponents. We have multiplication.
We have addition. We have division.
We have parentheses.
And so to interpret this properly,
we just have to remind ourselves
of the order of operations.
So you start with parentheses,
then go to exponents,
then multiplication and division,
then addition and subtraction.
So we see that we're going
to, whatever is over here,
we're eventually going to square it.
That's the only place that
we have the parentheses.
But how are we going to evaluate
what's inside of these parentheses?
So let's, then, think about, all right,
we have an exponent here
that we can evaluate.
We know that 2 squared is
the same thing as 2 times 2,
which is the same thing as 4.
No more exponents to evaluate.
So then we go to
multiplication and division.
So we know by how this
fraction sign is written
that we need to evaluate the numerator
and then divide it by
the entire denominator
right over here.
Now in this numerator, we
have to remind ourselves
that we do this multiplication
before we do this addition.
We don't just go left to right.
So we know that it's 1 plus,
and I could put parentheses
here to really emphasize
that we do the multiplication first.
So before this gets too messy,
let me just rewrite everything.
I'm going to do this
multiplication up here first,
and actually in the denominator
I'm going to do this
multiplication first as well.
So this is all going to
simplify to 1 over 14
or 1/14 times,
Now this numerator here is going to be
1 plus 4 times 3.
4 times 3 is 12.
All of that is going to be over
7 plus 2 times 3,
which is of course equal to 6.
And then I am going to
have our plus 1 here,
and then I square everything.
Well now we can evaluate this numerator
and this denominator.
Find another color to do it in.
This numerator, 1 plus 12,
is going to be equal to 13.
And 7 plus 6, interestingly,
is also equal to 13.
So we 1/14 or 1 divided by 14
times this whole thing squared,
and inside you have 13
divided by 13 plus 1.
Well, we know we need to do
division before we do addition.
So we will want to evaluate this part
before we do the addition.
What is 13 divided by 13?
Well that's just going to be equal to 1.
So I can rewrite this as 1 over 14
times 1 plus 1,
all of that squared.
And now we'll want to do this
parentheses. So let's do that.
1 plus 1 is going to be
equal, of course, to 2.
And then we're going to do the exponents.
2 squared is, of course, equal to 4.
And then we're going to
multiply 1 over 14 times 4.
Now you could interpret
this, and they're equivalent.
You could say, hey, this is the same thing
as multiplying 1/14 times 4.
Or you could say this is the same thing
as multiplying 1 times 4 divided by 14.
1 times 4 divided by 14.
Either way you look at it,
you're going to get 4
over 14, and we're done.
If you want, you could rewrite this
by dividing both the numerator
and the denominator by 2,
and you could get 2 over 7.
But that's how we can evaluate
this pretty complex expression
just step-by-step looking at
what we can simplify first.